so let's think about how to use this
we're going to do a few examples in
we're gonna expand down on this right so
let's consider now now you've got like a
new tool than your sandbox to play with
we know what happens to either the X if
you differentiate it but what if you
have some of its close cousins so for
example suppose you had something like
this guy right now if you wanted you
could pop this into desmos it would give
you a derivative it's an exponential so
I think unsurprisingly when you
differentiate you get another
exponential out but what exponential
will you get we have a rule for dealing
with these guys right when you have not
just a function but a function with
another function tucked inside it right
do you think back do you remember the
name of the rule that we use to deal
with differentiating functions with
other functions inside them we call this
the chain rule right in fact you may or
may not recall one of the longer names
it's a bit awkward so I'm going to use
it well the longer days for the chain
rule is the function of a function rule
sometimes the textbook will call it this
right there's a function and this is a
function of a function okay so when we
differentiate this what we need to say
is what's the derivative of the inside
function and what's the derivative of
the outside function
there's my insert function right there
what's the derivative of that thing just
5x what's its derivative it's just 5
isn't it like just to forget about this
for a second you don't have a different
shape it's just that 5
there's the derivative of the inside now
I'm going to deal with the derivative of
the outside what is the outside it's e
to the power of some stuff right what
happens when you differentiate e to the
power of some stuff see carefully
remember this is a unique function it's
different to our polynomials we've been
dealing over for yeah when you
differentiate e to the Paris of stuff
you get that this either
it doesn't change doesn't change right
so when you have a look at this right it
doesn't change you still have e to the
power of some stuff in this case the
stuff is 5x now
yeah it's it's crazy right now go to des
mots right don't don't just take my word
for right go ahead put in e to the 5x
this time instead of getting des Vosges
to do the derivative for you I want you
to put underneath this guy have a look 5
e to the 5x does it match up with what
des boss hands you have you got the same
kind of thing
have a look be careful with what you're
popping in there you got you might have
a lot of graphs there you may need to
clean that up a little bit so it was e
to the 5x e to the power of 5x
[Music]
all right so this is what I've got now I
know some of you may like wait a second
I can't really quite tell if this is
right you may have noticed when you went
into settings you can change a whole
bunch of things so one of the things
I've done is you know how you had your
original graph and then your blue one is
the derivative function right so that's
our answer that's what we're trying to
get but then we did this by hand so I
got 5 e to the 5x with you I've popped
that in as a green dotted graph so you
go into settings you can change it
because otherwise you kind of can't see
what's really going on because just on
top of each other hopefully you can see
this is not just close this is exactly
the same function okay so 5 e to the 5x
is my derivative when I get at the
bottom ok does this make sense I'm
following ok let's try another one
and this time I'm not going to do it up
on the screen I'm gonna get you guys to
test it out right instead of excuse me
the derivative of e to the 5x can you
tell me what the derivative of e to the
X minus 1 is can you work out what that
should be have a go see what you end up
with ok help me out because I saw a few
you have the answer we want to start
with the chain rule the derivative of
the inside what is it it's just 1 isn't
it because there's that inside function
X minus 1 I know how to differentiate
that it's just one there's the doing of
the inside now I deal with the outside
what is the outside it's it's e to the
power of some stuff
what have we established when you
differentiate e to the power some stuff
you get it just hands it straight back
to you right so I get this again right
yeah I wait a second
ah okay now what's going on right I said
before this is unique right and then
we've got something which seems to doing
the same thing now why should this be
the case tell me what is the difference
between this guy and this guy
I should have underlined this one here
this just minus one right but it's minus
one it's attached to the X do you notice
that right what happens if you take a
function like this right any function
you like and then what you do is you
attach a minus one to the X what happens
to it what's the difference between
these two it moves right where does it
move it moves one unit to the right in
this case you had the vertex at the
origin and zero and now you've got the
origin one unit to the right at one okay
so in other words these are the same
thing right just positioned differently
and these two functions are the same
function just in a different spot do you
see that I've just moved it over so no
surprises the derivative has not changed
does this make sense